weiß man denn mittlerweile schon was die
ermittler genau dort suchen in der
kleingarten partielle nein
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig und
bundeskriminalamt fühlen sich immer noch
in schweigen was sie hier genau suchen
die erdarbeiten wurden heute von den
beamten fortgesetzt und schauen was es
gibt also rein hypothetisch gesagt gibt
es drei optionen was man hier finden
könnte es wäre in erster linie natürlich
die sterblichen überreste von maddie
mccann ja wofür jetzt die spürhunde
sprechen die gestern ja auch schon im
einsatz waren
zweitens mögliche tatwerkzeuge das heißt
also sachen die christian b der hier
angeblich sich länger aufgehalten sollen
dieser kleinen gartenparzelle benutzt
haben könnte im zusammenhang mit diesem
mordfall und drittens haben wir
möglicherweise sind die kleidungsstücke
von maddie hier von christian b entsorgt
worden verbuddelt worden was auch immer
du hast gerade angesprochen kristján b
inwieweit stehen denn diese ermittlungen
jetzt immer noch um zu sagen haben mit
christian bei dem tatverdächtigen
naja also er hat hier gelebt
zu dem damals in hannover anderen zwei
unterschiedliche adressen
er soll wie gesagt was ich eben gerade
erwähnt habe diese kleingarten partielle
für sich auch benutzt haben und die
staatsanwaltschaft hat zumindest gesagt
dass hier die durchsuchung die die
erdarbeiten ausgeführt werden die
grabungen stehen ihm zusammen haben mit
dem ermittlungsfall maddie mccann vielen
dank mirko voltmer für deine aktuellen
informationen
ja und bei mir im studio ist jetzt der
profiler mark t hofmann guten morgen
herr hofmann
wir haben es gerade gehört es gibt neue
spurensuche sozusagen in hannover in
einer kleinen garten mit baggern wird
dort gebuddelt auch hunde kommen zum
einsatz worauf deutet das jetzt hin
genau ihr report hat er schon zusammen
gefasst es verschiedene möglichkeiten
gibt was da gesucht wird aber dinge
allerdings hat er eine möglichkeit glaub
ich vergessen oder unterschätzt was
durchaus auch möglich ist ich habe
gestern auch oft gelesen dass ein
spürhunde im einsatz also suchen sie
eine leiche ganz einfach ist es nicht
denn es gibt ja verschiedene arten von
spüren es gibt durchaus auch sprengstoff
hunde drogen spürhunde sogar bargeld
spürhunde und spüren die darauf
trainiert sind elektronik zu
erschnüffeln also zum beispiel
datenträger usb-sticks externe
festplatten oder auch handys und es gab
ja schon mal ein grundstück des
tatverdächtigen wo mehrere datenträger
gefunden wurden mit 8000 bildern und
videos unter anderem
kinderpornografisches material oder
missbrauchsdarstellungen das eigentlich
das korrekte wort das heißt es ist
durchaus auch möglich dass diese art von
beweismitteln gesucht werden denn die
staatsanwaltschaft hat bislang nur
bestätigt dass sie dort etwas suchen was
im zusammenhang mit dem mit den
ermittlungen im mordfall maddie mccann
steht sehen wir aber nicht gesagt dass
sie konkret dort nach einer leiche
suchen ist das durchaus auch möglich
dass sie nach datenträgern oder anderen
beweismitteln suchen aber natürlich ist
es möglich dass kleidungsstücke
vielleicht eine tat war von vielleicht
tatsächlich etwas was auf leichen oder
blog geruch hindeutet und
leichenspürhunde oder auch blut
spürhunde können ja nicht nur leichte
oder eigentlich können sie gar keine
leichen erschnüffeln sie können nur
leichten geruch wahrnehmen und der kann
ja durchaus auch an kleidungsstücken
tatwaffen oder anderen gegenständen
seien die längere zeit in der nähe einer
leiche gelegen haben und was auch immer
sie da suchen man kann nur hoffen dass
sie es finden denn die
staatsanwaltschaft scheint noch
puzzlestücke zu haben die die gerade
noch fehlen dennoch reicht es nicht
wirklich zu einer anklage sie haben es
gerade angesprochen es fehlen noch puls
stücke was fehlt dann genau wie kann man
den fall lösen
der fall ist extrem widersprüchlich
geworden und selbst für insider wie das
seit langer zeit verfolgen ist es
komplex geworden öffentlich bekannt sind
die vier wesentlichen indizien dass er
erstens da war
präziser formuliert dass sein handy da
war funkzellen erwartungen all diese
dinge sie können immer nur geräte orten
sie können ein handy ob sie können aber
nicht eine person orten
natürlich ist die annahme dass jemand
sein handy dabei hat relativ groß aber
jeder guter anwalt weiß dass man nur
sagen muss moment mal das beweist ja nur
dass das handy am tatort war aber nicht
mein nicht mein mandant und dann müssen
sie erst mal beweisen dass derjenige
auch das handy in der hand hatte an dem
abend
deswegen ist dieser anruf in der tat
macht so wichtig um zu zeigen dass nicht
nur das handy zur tatrelevanten zeit in
der nähe des tatorts war sondern auch er
das handy in der hand gehalten hat also
er war wahrscheinlich dort punkt 1
die vorlieben passende expressionismus
vorstrafen wegen kindesmissbrauch die
vier mutmasslichen vergewaltigung der
72-jährigen all diese dinge passen schon
ins profil und es scheint eine neigung
für wehrlose schwache opfer zu geben was
für ältere menschen und kinder
gleichermaßen zutrifft und all die
vorstrafen sexuellen motivierten
vorstrafen in summe sprechen klar dafür
außerdem einbrüche in hotel resort
anlagen das hat er auch der ermittler
vom bka gesagt dass es durchaus denkbar
ist dass diese tat als einbruch begonnen
hat und als entführung geendet hat denn
sie ist ja aus einer hotelanlage
verschwunden und vielleicht denn das ist
eine große frage die niemand so richtig
beantworten kann wie kann jemand das
alleine geplant haben ohne gesehen zu
werden
man hätte ja die familie eine woche
absolvieren müssen man hätte schauen
müssen wo die kinder schlafen dass die
terrassentür offen sind
weil das wirklich alles bekannt oder war
media zur falschen zeit am falschen ort
und ein victim of opportunity also
zufalls zufallsopfer in dem fall wenn es
nur ein geplanter einbruch war auch das
verhalten nach der tat dieser
telefonanruf nach der mutmasslichen tat
muss man sagen denn noch ist er immer
noch gilt auch für ihn die
unschuldsvermutung
dieses telefonat sein auto soll er einen
tag danach um gemeldet haben und für
einige jahre portugal verlassen haben
das sind summe ist eine plausible
theorie aber es ist nur eine theorie
aber die staatsanwaltschaft hat ja ein
beweismittel was sie noch nie
veröffentlicht haben sie sagen sie haben
einen beweis gestützten verdacht das
mittelmeer käm tot ist und dass
christian b der tatverdächtige schuldig
ist sie ermordet zu haben was dieser
beweis gestützte verdacht ist haben sie
aber noch nicht gesagt so beweis
gestützt scheint er aber auch nicht zu
sein zumindest gab es bislang keine
vernehmung keine anklage kein haftbefehl
das heißt es gibt sicherlich noch lücken
die offen sind sonst wären sie auch
nicht zu aktenzeichen xy gegangen und
würden permanent die öffentlichkeit um
beweise bitten was ist nötig um den fall
zu lösen nach wie vor entweder ein
geständnis oder zeugen oder eine leiche
es wird doch sehr sehr schwer mord an zu
klagen oder zu verurteilen wenn man
keine leiche hat dann könnte es doch
dünn werden und im moment scheint es
noch nicht auszureichen
und deswegen sind ja mehr als 800
zeugenhinweise eingegangen die werden
jetzt natürlich abarbeitet und
abgearbeitet und geprüft und einer
dieser hinweise hat möglicherweise auch
auf diese kleinen gartenanlage in
hannover geführt was auch immer sie da
suchen
ich hoffe sehr dass es finden